crypto advocates venture capitalists and
anti-establishment libertarians alike
are obsessed with web 3 and fair enough
web 3 is incredibly confusing it's
controversial here's why
the early web back in the good old days
was composed of static pages of images
and text in what became known as web 2.0
things became interoperable users began
interacting with each other sharing
pictures and videos and opinions but
they need to find a big platform in
order to read them or be offended by
them which led to today's landscape of
giant mega corporations sucking up all
that data and selling ads against it
web 3 advocates argue that government
can't force the tech giants to do any
better via regulation so it's time for a
new model where we create and own the
web experience that we want or more
accurately what the advocates think we
should want
i'll use some broad comparisons to help
build a picture of what this experience
with web3 looks like today web3 today is
most easily experienced in the form of a
decentralized app or dap which pulls
data from the ethereum blockchain rather
than a general purpose web browser which
downloads everything from a single
company's bank of servers a few thousand
apps are active and listed on
directories like dap radar and most tend
to have specific uses such as crypto
trading or gaming the blockchain
fundamentally a ledger or permanent
record is stored and mirrored across
thousands of computers or nodes owned
and operated by anyone i could own one i
don't you could own one you might
by storing their most important data on
that distributed blockchain rather than
a central database these web 3 apps
remove a crucial single point of failure
centralized mega corporations like
facebook or google or the many others
data written to the blockchain can't be
changed only ever added to and those
editions are copied to all nodes since
everyone has a copy of the same data
forgery and takedowns are practically
impossible it's not a million miles
actually away from the thinking behind
bittorrent just think back to how hard
it was for the music industry to shut
down people file sharing when they were
basically just copying mp3s from one
computer to another rather than from a
web server that could be seized in a
police raid
this is only a small part of what makes
web 3 different someone needs to pay for
running these nodes putting up the power
and the bandwidth plus you still need a
way to access that distributed data in
the first place the financial incentive
to the people who create or help develop
an app in web 3 is a token that gives
them a say over the fees it charges and
how it evolves these tokens can be sold
or given away and you only need to look
at nfts to know that tokens can be
extremely valuable
right now a significant early adopter
needs to be bankrolled though and the
big money's coming from the investment
firms like andreessen horowitz vcs
invested about 30 billion last year in
crypto and web 3 projects according to
pitchbook
and it's for this very reason that some
important industry figures have
dismissed the idea of web 3 being a
democratic online utopia jack dorsey for
instance twitter's former chief
executive officer mocked it as a
creature of silicon valley vc firms and
limited partnerships furthermore many
gateways to a web 3 experience are built
using familiar web 1 and web 2
technologies and regular cloud-based
servers like aws because the blockchain
itself can't be used for storing large
files or giant repositories of code
meaning again there's technically a
single point of failure in the hands of
at least one mega corporation
and isn't that the whole point that
we're meant to be moving away from a
centralized web
the reality is that we're so early in
the development that everyone can be
right and wrong about the technology on
any given day or with whom you're
actually speaking what we're seeing is
experimentation trial and error quite a
lot of market speculation and definitely
a lot of fear of missing out
but in order to scale web3 will need to
borrow from some of the best innovations
made during the web 1 and web 2 eras as
is technology's way of course while
implementing key technologies that made
cryptocurrencies possible in the first
place it's going to take years of
research billions of dollars many
arguments with regulators debates in
academia and at some point i'm sure law
suits when someone thinks they've been
decentralized out of a refund for quick
take in london i'm nate langston and
i've been technically speaking